[موسيقى]
تشبه شريحه لحم حقيقيه لكنها لحوم نباتيه
بالكامل ومطبوعه بتقنيه ثلاثيه الابعاد
انه الجيل المقبل من اللحوم وهو من صنع
شركه اسبانيه
استعد العمال في المصنع التجريبي الجديد
لبدء الانتاج خطوه الى الامام في محاوله
لاعاده تعريف اللحوم في اطار خطط طموحه
للمشروع بان يكون اكبر شركه لحوم بديله في
العالم بحلول عام 2030 من ستارز
كثير من الشركات الناشئه بدات بالفعل
بتصنيع اللحوم وشرائح الدجاج منذ سنوات
مثل
وتستخدم تقنيات المعروفه في هذا القطاع
لكن التحدي اليوم هو اطلاق الجيل الجديد
من هذا الاختراع والمتمثل في ابتكار نسيج
مطابق للحوم فالمستهلكون لا يرغمون فقط
بتذوق طعم اللحم بل يريدون تجربه حسيه
مشابهه لتناول اللحم والدجاج
انتاج الاجزاء والانسجه الدقيقه من اللحوم
المصنعه عمليه معقده يقول مسؤول هذه
الشركه انهم باتوا يتقنونها باستخدام
تقنيه الطباعه ثلاثيه الابعاد كانت هذه
التكنولوجيا رائعه لانشاء نماذج اوليه
بسرعه لكن التحدي الان ايجاده اله لصناعه
قطع لحوم بشكل سريع وعلى نطاق تجاري اوسع
وهو ما تمكنت الشركه من القيام به عبر اله
سريه تخضع لحراسه مشدده بعيدا عن عدسات
الكاميرا
بدانا العمل بطابعه ثلاثيه الابعاد ولكن
فيما بعد انشانا اله ضخمه خاصه بنا لنتمكن
من صناعه قطع لحم كبيره وبتفاصيل دقيقه
وبكميات وافره
مجموعه من المنتجات باستخدام مكونات
مختلفه فالدجاج في خط الانتاج هذا مكون من
بروتين البازلاء وعصير الشمندر والطحالب
وزيت عباد الشمس على مدى السنوات الخمس
الماضيه ازدهر قطاع اللحوم نباتيه مع ظهور
موجه من الشركات الناشئه التي تستفيد من
زياده طلب المستهلكين على بدائل لحوم
الحيوانات
فروعه بالاهتمام بالمزايا الصحيه للحوم
النباتيه ورعايه الحيوانات
وتقليل بعثات الكربون